all right the name of the game new word
new joke in just 10 minutes for better
or worse sometimes these go better than
others but I appreciate you all for
hanging out and running along with me
and challenging yourselves to level up
your own writing
and today's word of the day
is royal
which we generate every day in our
Facebook group a new word of the day
for people to write jokes on and then I
do this live stream every Wednesday at
10 A.M so come on back and join the full
live stream next week but in the
meantime the word of the day is Royal so
for the next 10 minutes
we are writing a joke using this word
now you can write along with me feel
free to share ideas as I'm talking
through them I try to talk through my
process
and sometimes I end up with a joke
sometimes I don't but you watching this
we will find out together today so
10 minutes on the clock
that's right
all right so with the word of the day
Royal I always like to start out with
associations and uh by the way the pin
I'm using is the Paper Mate
profile
pin
one I found at Target you know just
trying something new it's got a good
heft to it it's a metal Barrel so that's
something new and different
let's see if we can write a joke with it
as we've already killed 25 seconds so
Royal what do we think of I mean just to
start brainstorming
royal blue Royal Purple
royalty
a royal
pain
in the blue
come on I'm dressed like a youth pastor
I'm not gonna say
how about real pain in the butt
um there's another phrase royally
screwed
so basically
I like to start off the first few
minutes
just brainstorming creating associations
when I hear this word Royal what do I
think of it could be common phrases it
could be idioms it could be analogies
uh it could be whatever you think of I
see say said royal family
yep that's a good one there
royal family is a good one and as you go
further
you can think of okay
what do I think of when I hear the word
Royals okay so if you say royal family
then what do you think of it may be king
Queen
maybe Buckingham Palace
it may be
imperialism wait no colonialism
I should know this I like a colonizer
um
I think it's colonialism
yeah and even further you know uh Royal
Family king queen maybe you think of
crowns
Thrones okay
so Throne can then be also known as
toilet
so there's an opportunity there maybe
for a joke because a lot of Comedy comes
down to
finding connections you know comedy
hinges on surprise so whether that's
through a surprising misdirect with a
setup punch it's a surprising analogy
where you compare one thing to another
that doesn't seem related
or it's something so another surprising
connection with I hear Royal and then I
mate to toilet so maybe there's a funny
leap we can make there within our joke
writing but for now we're just
brainstorming
Mary says Casino Royale
kalana says Royal Wedding yeah yeah
that's another that could be
with um
the royal family or royal pain in the
butt as well
royalty program
says Lance Mike jump said Royale with
cheese from Pulp Fiction yeah yeah yeah
so we got some good ideas swirling
around here
Royal Purple royal blue royalty
royal pain in the butt royally screwed
royal family royal wedding
um oh that's funny say brought up royal
family with beds like king queen Etc
yeah that's funny
something with royal and toilet is
really singing to me though
so
um
oh yeah kalana said royal family castle
night gesture Jester oh yeah the king's
Jester maybe like a royal jester
so there could be something about
uh like a self-deprecating comedian joke
or something making fun of yourself
the Royal Jester which is a royal pain
in the butt so it's like my family
used to call me a royal pain in the butt
but now I get paid to be the Royal
Jester or
but I preferred the term Royal jester
could be you know it could be a funny
connection you make there
um
so let's see here
if I can think of okay how can we go
from
Royal
throne
toilet so
when it comes to actually generating
your ideas whatever you have when it
comes to now structuring it into a joke
it starts with the premise it starts
with what am I trying to say here
so for Royal Throne toilet
what is a premise that I could be
playing around with here or what are
ways that I can create and a premise is
basically like what is the joke about
what is the message of the joke
every joke has a premise
and it it's basically a way to sum up
your joke within a single line or phrase
or what am I trying to say
in this joke ask yourself that a lot of
times if a joke isn't working it's
probably because the premise isn't clear
enough to the audience
so Royal Throne toilets
sneeze
damn
all right Royal Throne toilet so what
can I say with this
but that could also play with royal pain
in the butt as well being on the throne
you know
um
so just to brainstorm
after
tacos
which even to be more specific could be
after Chipotle
and there may be a food that's more
connected to royalty that we could after
fish and chips I don't know
after Burger King
after eating Burger King
I was stuck
on the throne
AKA toilet
um
so that's I mean you know
as we're brainstorming here that's not
terrible
oh thank you people for blessing me for
the sneeze and Mike jump said I'm a
comic in Mexico
in Spanish the word for premise and
setup is the same okay way
thank you for sharing that
uh so after you Burger King I was stuck
on the throne okay
I know
oh but he's the word Royal in it
Royal throne
could be put in there Royal Throne I
think that still says
um I know why they call
it
Burger
King
after eating it
you're stuck
the throne
and if Royal you know to squeeze the
word in there I would say Royal throne
um
I know why they call it Burger King
after eating it you're stuck on the
Royal throne
for
really for wording sake Royal isn't
really necessary there
you could just say you're stuck on the
throne
[Music]
um
so how can we keep um
how can we keep refining this here I
mean right now it's kind of a silly poop
joke but I mean in 10 minutes you know
these aren't all going to be Keepers and
jokes we do on stage the whole point of
this exercise is to
practice writing and holding ourselves
accountable to right
so it's creating this 10 minute exercise
that come on can you spare 10 minutes
out of 24 hours
to work on your comedy writing because
it's a muscle the more you write the
stronger it gets
so I know why they call it Burger King
after eating it you're stuck on the
Royal throne
so
so we could use the word wrong different
way
Burger King
is royal
food
after eating it
you're stuck
on the throne
rid of royal pain
yeah I see that I see that one
from Sandy Ed said I know why they call
it Burger King after I ate there I had
to see an enema specialist to get a
royal flush oh my gosh
that is so funny Royal Flush could be
another good tag
ooh Russell Jay said Burger King gives
your stomach the Royal Rumble oh that's
good too
Sandy said the tag could be royal pain
in the butt or ass
oh Michelle had a good way to tighten it
up Burger King is Royal food after
eating it you visit the throne oh I like
that one
and I like the word economy of that one
too Michelle that it's instead of like
you're stuck on the throne
you visit the throne I like how that's
Tighter and more concise and there may
be a funnier way to even say it be on
visit
or you're stuck on the throne
um
but for 10 minutes I don't hate it
so do post your jokes on the comments
and uh we do this live writing exercise
every single Wednesday at 10 A.M eastern
time on this YouTube channel so do
subscribe set a reminder to come join us
live and ride along with us
have a good day
yay